the US troops have left under a hail of
paint
stones and vegetables thrown in disgust
its material in the history and bitter
words from their former partners which
may come back to haunt the Americans a
few hundred US soldiers are expected to
stay inside North Syria guarding the oil
fields rather than the Kurdish people or
fighters so they're not taken over by is
in Turkey the clock is ticking and the
country's president and his ministers
are keeping count with the deadline for
the Kurdish withdrawal fast running out
so we have 36 35 hours left if they
don't withdraw our operation will
restart Turkish backed forces have now
moved into the Syrian border town of
Rassilon which seems to be empty of its
citizens two weeks ago it was packed
with people the YPG bases have been
deserted by their fighters but they seem
to have taken all their weaponry with
them and that won't satisfy the Turks
who made it a stipulation of the pause
and fighting home after home is now
empty with Kurdish commanders calling it
the biggest ethnic cleansing operation
of the 21st century carried out in front
of the American armies eyes in the midst
of this are hundreds of children in
three YPG camps at least 60 are thought
to be British earlier this year we spoke
to British mothers accused of being is
in al Raj camp and too scared to be
identified and that's very dangerous
we're sitting in Syria yeah yeah and you
don't know what's going to happen one
charity says the children urgently need
to be repatriated these children have
had no to this they found that somewhere
in the middle of Syria they don't in
some cases don't know why they're here
and now as a global community we're
telling them we don't want you because
we don't know what your parents may or
may not have done and now there are
worries that access to the camps will be
lost after the Kurds struck a deal with
the Syrian regime
Alex Crawford Sky News in Turkey